okay and
for the alpha County yes
I don't want to use that I don't want to
use it they don't an Arizona judge is
charged with a DUI after her blood
alcohol content tests nearly three times
the legal limit the entire incident
caught on body camera video
I'm a judge here
oh okay well I apparently I apologize
I've never met you it's good that you
never know
back in March Prescott Arizona Police
received multiple calls for a person
acting erratically at a Safeway grocery
store
[Music]
find her balance
I prefer
10 seconds and then
so I sat in my driver's seat for a
minute a minute we're driving away body
camera video shows Prescott police
officials catching up with Yavapai
County Superior Court Judge Saleh
Hancock what's going on today ma'am
okay well we got some reports that you
were inside of Safeway
and you're walking around stumbling and
you got back in your vehicle
and you left the store
and now you're here
okay do me a favor and turn off your car
so I can hear you
perfect
so my next question to you Mammoth have
you been drinking today you haven't been
drinking today
okay are you having a medical condition
today or medical issue
okay so would there be a reason that
somebody would call and say that maybe
you're stumbling around in Safeway
okay
okay so why'd you leave your wallet at
the store
okay Hancock tells officers she was at
the Safeway pharmacy to pick up her
prescription where she accidentally
forgot her wallet because we're getting
prescriptions and it makes me ask
other medications around that maybe you
haven't taken today
uh
okay
oh okay I'm asking is there any medical
concerns that we'd have created like I
asked you this is your disorder what is
it I have a seizure oh okay well that's
good to know because then that makes us
wonder if they're seeing something maybe
at the store maybe there's an incident
that may have happened that you weren't
aware of with seizures I just have to
ask and that's the medical side I can
ask that as an EMT I can ask was there
any medical concerns that maybe you were
feeling today okay were you by chance
were you having anything of the store
when you're at the store because I've
seen that where people might be walking
and all of a sudden they hit something
you don't realize it I don't think so
but I
seizure disorder okay and you're not
feeling like you're having an incident
right now
between here and the storm
okay
I'm asking just I know to help you out
that's awesome just work with us and I
want to be as cooperative and helpful as
I can with you
perfect it's then that Hancock admits
she's been drinking have you had any
alcohol some have you consumed any
alcohol today earlier today earlier
today like when you mean earlier how
earlier
hours ago how much did you drink
okay and were you at home when you did
this or were you out you're at home okay
officers then asked the judge to perform
field sobriety tests if you have bad
knees and you're convinced that your
knees are going to keep you from
performing the test I don't know
hey go ahead
go ahead
how about are you able to stand on one
on one leg
I don't know are you yeah
stand on one leg
let's try go ahead okay
please sure I can so if you're gonna
have her do that if you're not going to
have her do the walk and turn test
because because of her bad knees then
you need to know that that because of
her bad knees you chose not to have her
do this this portion of it but
yeah she's gonna go ahead and try to do
the one leg stand okay okay and what the
one leg stand is you need to explain to
her on what you're wanting her to do so
she understands what's going on okay
I'm gonna put this in your car is that
okay okay I'm gonna put it on the
driver's seat while keeping both legs
straight point the toe of your raised
foot down look at the raised foot and
keep your arms to your side it's gonna
look like this
okay you're gonna pick one foot and
stand to your side
and you're gonna look down at your toes
the whole time for how long until I tell
you okay I'm not done yet I'm not done
yet
that's all right
while in this position count out loud in
the following matter 1001 1002 1003 and
so forth until I tell you to stop
it's gonna look like this
while you're looking down at your toes
thousand and one one thousand and two
one thousand and three one thousand and
four until I tell you to stop
do you understand yes
okay
did you ask
did you ask her do you have bad ankles
I have bad feet by angles I've been
everything okay how about those shoes
are they pretty comfortable shoes
I'm just asking yes okay all right and
out of both of your legs which leg is
the most
uh they're both bad okay which one is
not not as bad that was bad okay okay so
it's your choice once late you're gonna
raise
okay okay
okay they're all they're both bad okay
okay
what am I supposed to do
when's the timing starting
it's already started
Hancock then takes the breathalyzer test
where she blows a 0.219 so have you ever
done one of these before memories no
okay so go and explain to her how she's
supposed to do okay yeah
steady fresh steady flow
for as long as I tell Youtube it'll stop
okay it's getting steady all the way
through do you understand yeah have you
ever blown up a balloon an air balloon
so just do a steady breath of air just
like that like you're blowing up a
balloon okay
okay perfect
[Music]
go to jail no we're not saying you're
going to jail man
at this point an officer tells Hancock
he believes she's over the legal limit
so here's the deal man okay I'm gonna be
completely honest with you okay so I
think your yours your signs and symptoms
are above
the legal limit okay okay and that's
that's just based off of my experience
that's fair enough after this Hancock
tells multiple officers that she's a
judge in the area you
are yeah
okay and for the upper County yes
I don't want to use that I don't want to
use it I don't okay uh I really don't I
really don't and I'm so you know what in
my videos
I'm a judge here
oh okay well I apparently I apologize
I've never met you it's good that you
never have it
multiple times Hancock repeats she's
quote just a normal person you've been
very sweet and we appreciate that
it shouldn't mean anything
you know just a person like everybody
else
I'm just a normal person like everybody
else I'm just a normal person like and
all I understand shouldn't matter that's
okay um
we're gonna go we're just gonna have you
stay in my in my patrol car for now okay
get you out of the weather yeah so
you're not getting water on you right
the rain be like
last month Hancock pleaded guilty to the
lowest level DUI charge she was
sentenced to just one day behind bars
and now owes a sixteen hundred dollar
fine according to her attorney she's now
undergoing a rehab program reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie